freude herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge einen tag persönlicher koch
und endlich hört dass fragen in den
kommentaren auf ich habe hier niemand
geringeren als meinen alten freund
justin leben hier etwas geht und ich
werde einmal unbedingt gerne danke dass
du hier bist ich werde heute ein tag
natürlich kochen du hast hier empfehle
sachen gewünscht und es bleibt uns
eigentlich nichts anderes übrig als
historische kloster letztlich habe
hunger mit geworden fangen wir an mit
dem frühstück ist schon alles
vorbereitet wir haben in maine
charakterfesten brötchen und ich sage
euch so viel es hätte nicht so sein
sollen es hätten dort keine fertigen
post brötchen liegen sollen nicht
umsonst eigentlich aus zwei stunden
aufgestanden und habe angefangen welche
selbst hat aber einfach nicht
funktioniert unter
[Musik]
halb so wild wir machen das beste draus
denn wir haben ansonsten die feinsten
zutaten für eine premium version von
einem mac muffins das hat justin mir
vorgegeben und im feinsten geräuchertem
schinken wir haben jetta sie haben
botschaft frischem thymian und hier
hinten haben wir zutaten für eine
thematische mayonnaise also für eine
spicy mayonnaise und die machen wir als
allererstes schnappen uns eine schüssel
und geben in diese schüsse natürlich nur
von der feinsten kopie mayonnaise 120
gramm so kann man doch den tag starten
es ist eine ganze menge dann dazu 80
gramm creme fraiche knoblauch pulver und
geräucherte paprika jeweils acht gramm
und dann je nach gewünschtem schärfegrad
ich mache erst mal nicht so viel weil
ich weiß nicht genau wie gerne jobs sind
scharf mag außerdem noch zwei teelöffel
worcester songs schreibt nicht dass man
es anders aus sprich sind man spricht
zuerst das vermengen jetzt alles error
log es entsteht eine traumhafte soße
kaum scharf so wie sie jetzt ist ein
traditioneller macguffin hat gar keine
soße drauf aber es ist eine schöne
ergänzung sagt auch dann schauen wir uns
zunächst unseren schinken es gibt ja
menschen in verschiedenen ausführungen
bacon dies das aber was das war das
schönste was bekommen konnte es ist ein
mit rucola aromatisierter schinken aus
dem ich jetzt quasi in größeres brötchen
kreise herausstechen selbst also ich
muss niemandem erzählen dass das was
nicht heraus gestochen wurde auch
gegessen wird weil das ist normal
außerdem brauchen wir auf unserem
sandwich shader-einheiten will vergessen
und dann natürlich denn dann werden wir
diese form direkt wieder brauchen so wir
machen unseren herd an geben einen guten
stich butter hinein so thorsten dann
gleich in dieser fahne einmal und so
brüchen an unserem muffin wollte was
eigentlich macht das ding ist das heißt
nicht nur in amerika so ein bisschen
heißer wird auf jeden fall ein schöner
trost einmal dran dann können wir das
auch schon beiseite legen und ansonsten
ist es wirklich ein kinderspiel das
einzig schwierige während wie gesagt der
teig gewesen aber das wollte ja nicht so
richtig kann man halt dann machen wir
gleich hier drüben unsere noch fertig
dann läuft das so wenn es so schön
goldbraun an gerüstet ist wie hier
einfach einmal wenden und der rückseite
auch noch einen kleinen trost geben dann
geht es auch schon richtig los jetzt
geht es schlag auf schlag so dann können
wir das ganze auch schnappen und zur
seite legen eigentlich direkt schon
wieder butter nachlegen so dann geben
wir jetzt in die geschmolzene butter
unseren schinken und dazu ein wenig im
jahr an frischem thymian und darin
besten wir das ganze jetzt heißt dass
wir während es an dreht einfach
kontinuierlich obendrüber diese
automatisierte thymian butter geben noch
mehr geschmeckt reinzubekommen damit das
ganze schön gleichmäßig angebraten wird
gebe ich noch eine top obendrauf kann
man natürlich auch machen mit diesen
kerlen mit dem man smash burger markt
kann meine gerade verlegt dann nehme ich
diesen job zu kriegen wir schön
gleichmäßig röstaromen daran und
parallel fange ich hübsch machen vor zu
heizen dann nochmal ein wenig futter so
einfach schön dass in butter obendrüber
geben es sieht jetzt schon sehr sehr gut
aus so wie schnappen uns unsere vormund
schlagen einfach ein hinein so krieg das
perfekt diese runde form von trust
brötchen und braten das ganze jetzt
erstmal hier von einer seite an eingeben
hier oben drauf noch schneller schmilzt
jetzt schön mit an und hier drüben ist
das schön langsam ein wenig geschockt
wir gehen noch einen deckel drauf wenn
das ei unten gestoppt ist geben wir
außen rum ein wenig wasser und machen
einfach den deckel drauf dass das auch
von so sieht unser aus wenn es fertig
ist eine runde scheibe drücken können
wir es auch mal ausmachen und käse
geschmolzen dann brauchen wir jetzt
nicht viel außer ein wenig von unserer
selbst gemacht die warschauer beiden
seiten natürlich und brauchen wir nur
noch zwei treffer auf 3 den wir auch
noch oben drauf und zuletzt das ganze
geht doch schön
hier setzen wir jetzt also justin was
vor der ein ensemble von getränken er
und natürlich den weg machen was segen
geholt
okay ich bin sehr gespannt also ich sag
mal optik ist sie im madison ganz
kleinen schritt voraus oder das
schmerzlich also erst erst jetzt 88 88
ich erwarte heute ja mach das gerne das
ist natürlich die frage euch
geschmacklich auch hinter max abschneide
wenn ich darf nichts sagen du darfst
nicht allzu viel sagen hat natürlich
seinen ersten eindruck weil lassen es
sieht halt schon sehr schwer
also man muss aufpassen
also wir sehen uns gleich leute
schlachtfeld
ich habe jetzt auch eingegriffen und ich
verstehe was für mainz sehr fällt
auseinander und der macht so geist kann
gesagt ne das ist vielleicht jetzt nicht
so aus weil sich diese klein groß
zimmern der macht ernst solch wird zur
bewertung kommt unbedingt okay ich gebe
eine neun von zehn euro ha weil der war
wirklich krank dass alba fluffig der
schinken war perfekt das brötchen mal
geil quatsch das einzige warum nicht
auch nur neun und nicht sehen weil die
soße die hat für mich nicht ganz so
perfekt zum weib gepasst aber sonst war
ich fühle was vermeintlich erstmal danke
für die gute bewertung da war diese
geräusche paprika die hat war sehr
präsent das muss man mögen ich
persönlich ganz geil aber so diese ganze
textur war schon keller kann sachen
nicht zu dieser diesem meckels teil
dieses american es ist einfach eine
premiere wir haben merkt eigentlich bist
was du zu mittag essen sagen würde es
gibt juni als heim ohne und wir sehen
wie gesagt ravioli mit lachs hier steht
auch schon alles was wir haben dazu gibt
es eine kleine weißwein schaum soße und
wir fangen an indem wir den teig für die
ravioli machen ich habe mir auch noch
mal so eine nudel aufsatz hergeholt ist
das ganze ein bisschen schilliger die
haben wir 400 gramm doppelnull mail die
geben wir erst mal in unsere schlüssel
hinein weil wir gerne heute morgen
sondern einfach mit dazu wir machen hier
noch mal so eine kleine kuhle in der
mitte aber nur fürs auge gehen wir vier
eier und dazugeben jetzt noch zwei
esslöffeln olivenöl und steine erstmal
die maschine an und lassen das ganze
knick welche drüben jetzt der teig
knetet kann man wir uns um die füllung
der ravioli ich habe hier 400 gramm
lachsfilet frisch bolt gestern das
entfernen wir erstmal von der haut sagt
natürlich auch von geräten befreien und
unser lachsfilet schneiden wir schon mal
in würfel das wird gleich alles einfach
im mixer durch püriert gemeinsam mit den
anderen zutaten für die füllung also
ganz ganz einfach wir machen es zu mixen
nur ein bisschen leichter indem wir
schon mal vor schneiden dazu kommen
einfach 250 gramm ricotta und eine
gekochte kartoffel bisschen gehen wir
auch mit dem gefühl und ich sagen in der
zwischenzeit ist auch unser teig fertig
geknetet schon für die pasta schönen
struktur bekommt den werden jetzt in
frischhaltefolie einwickeln ich hätte
noch ein bisschen durch auf der
arbeitsfläche ich habe die kugel geformt
auf frischhaltefolie gegeben und so
lassen wir den jetzt werden wir den rest
vorbereiten einfach ein bisschen ruhm
also nehmen jetzt einfach alles gegeben
dass hier in unserer nichts hinein sind
schon also man sieht schon dass das echt
nice alex ist das ist wirklich denkbar
einfach also gerade wenn man mit so
einer maschine der arbeiten kann
das ließ denkt man das nicht aber wenn
man es als deckel drauf
und beim mixen geben wir je nachdem wie
viel benötigt etwas koch sahne dazu
hilft auf jeden fall dass es leichter
mixed aber man guckt erstmal braucht und
so sieht die masse aus wenn sie fertig
ist wir sind noch ein paar kleine
stückchen drin zum beispiel bot
kartoffel oder so aber das möchte man ja
auch mal wieder auch ein bisschen textur
haben in seinem rolli dementsprechend
aushält und ein wenig gerührt und wir
fangen jetzt an das ganze aus rollen
deshalb erstmal die arbeitsfläche mailen
freue mich auf diese dinge
auszuprobieren weil wie gesagt noch nie
gemacht packen wir den tag erstmal aus
bisschen mehr gehe ich noch mal dran wir
arbeiten jetzt nur mit einem viertel den
rest decken wir wieder ab mit der uns
nicht austrocknet so jetzt wird es
spannend leute wir stellen hier nämlich
mal an auf größter stufe kommen wir
jetzt erstmal in klassischen rechteck
wollen das jetzt einmal durch das
natürlich sollte ich sage dir ehrlich
das ist so viel entspannter als mit der
kleinen maschine von anzukurbeln
natürlich nicht ganz so handwerklich
dann aber wir gehen auf jeden fall schon
relativ dünn mit dem ganzen die finalen
ravioli kriegen ja auch quasi zwei lagen
noch dementsprechend muss das wirklich
dünn sein ist fertig sind so nummer eins
ist fertig wir machen jetzt gerade
nummer zwei und dann können wir auch
schon gefüllt wie seit jetzt kräftig das
nudelwasser weil ansonsten haben wir
eigentlich noch gar nicht mit seite
arbeitet dementsprechend kann da
wirklich ordentlich was rein ich wähle
dann nochmal die arbeitsfläche dass uns
auch wirklich nicht unser tag hier
antreten wird dann können wir die
unschönen stücke am ende einfach
abtrennen dann nehmen uns unsere füllung
wenn man so einen guten teelöffel
bisschen das so schön mittig ein paar
zentimeter 15 weiteren gerade anzahl
sich dafür auf dem teller oder dann ist
noch mal spannend schnappen wir uns das
ganze hier legen es einfach einmal oben
drauf normalerweise würde man den haft
verteidigten aber ich glaube der ist so
klebrig ist und jetzt luft ausschließen
sonst geht das ganze blätter auch
unschön an und jetzt dachte ich mir
probiere ich diese rund auszuschneiden
dass wir jetzt unsere nudeln und geben
die ganz vorsichtig ins wasser hinein
und ich hoffe sehr dass die nicht
aufgehen werden weil das ist natürlich
eine sache die ich nicht kontrollieren
kann aber ich finde an sich sehen sie
schon richtig gemacht haben dann warten
wir jetzt bis sie uns komplett
hochschulen so die mühlen sind jetzt
fertig wir richten an und dann sehen wir
uns gleich im westen
da sind wir dann auch mittagessen
ravioli mit lachs führung gewünscht
hatte wir sind noch ein bisschen
abgewichen von der weisheit schaun soße
weil du nicht so gern weiß wer mag kann
mit einem einfach ein paar fein gehackte
getrocknete tomaten obendrauf und jetzt
ist er gerne schmecken ok also ein
bisschen soße von den getrockneten
tomaten mit drin ja genau darüber
gegeben die schwellung ist ob firmen
gerne also nicht die firma graf
erfindungen
[Musik]
ich hab allerdings sei dank nicht so
schlecht zu sein wir sind uns gleich
wieder das war's teller ist leer ja ich
selbst noch ausprobiert ich muss sagen
es ist ungefähr halb so leicht diese
praxis bürger ja der bürger leute das
war unfassbar also der liegt so
geisteskranke magen dagegen war das
wirklich ein drittel oder die hälfte 40
geschmeckt neuneinhalb von cfs australia
das war so wirklich unfassbar lecker das
einzige was man noch minimal hätte
verbessern können was der lachs
vielleicht minimal intensiver raus
kommen weil in dem restaurant wo ich das
ab und zu kleine es da ist es irgendwie
minimal intensiver aber auch wirklich
das meckern auf hohem niveau was
wirklich geistes kann gewesen sein ich
fand es auch sehr sehr lecker auch diese
variante auch nicolas ihr geschmeckt hat
und wir sehen uns gleich zum abendessen
wieder würde ja dann fröhlich hat moto
am meisten auffällt ich bin sehr
gespannt kommen wir zum abendessen und
wie gesagt ich freue mich sehr darauf
denn es gibt dina schnitzel mit
getrüffeltem kartoffelpüree an frischem
trüffel dementsprechend wird es sehr
extravagant kann mich ja nicht lumpen
lassen denn etwas sind heute hier ist
und wir fangen an mit dem kartoffelpüree
indem wir erstmal diese ganzen
kartoffeln schälen so ich hatte
kartoffel soll ein gleichmäßiges stücke
geschnitten und dann können wir sie auch
schon ins kochende wasser geben sondern
setzen wir die kartoffel noch großzügig
und nicht nur die kartoffeln setzen wir
denn auch unsere pannierstraße wird
gesalzen und das war nicht so wie ich
sage nämlich die gesamte pannierstraße
krieg pfeffer und salz ab und
semmelbröseln dann natürlich auch das
und auch das doppel griffige meeres
zusammen ist mit deshalb besonders gut
anhaftet wir nehmen uns unsere schnitzel
die sind wie sich für ein wiener
schnitzel gehört aus der calwer schale
geschnitten wie man sehen kann extrem
fein ist noch dazu wir bereiten die
flach aus dann schnappen wir uns unseren
platz ihr hammer und arbeiten uns
langsam vor nicht zu fest weil wir
natürlich die struktur des fleischs
verletzten wollen und keine risse
reinmacht das ist eine schöne form denn
perfektes schnitzel getobt und erstmal
ein wenig ab natürlich auch vorher schon
man muss man nicht dadurch dass wir die
kartoffeln klein geschnitten haben
kochen sie auch schneller und sind jetzt
schon fertig nach 15 minuten und können
das gerne mal ein bisschen länger
dauernd sodann tropfen wir sehr gut ab
das getan ist geben wir sie wieder
zurück in den topf der herd ist jetzt
aber mittlerweile aus und mit zu den
kartoffeln sondern lassen sie erst mal
ruhe geben wir schon mal einen guten
schluck milch das sind ungefähr so 150
milliliter außerdem kommt dazu jetzt
eine ordentliche ecke butter aber auch
innovationen für vier personen ein
großzügiger schluck trüffelöl das ist
nicht so super geschmacksintensiv also
je nachdem wie stark alles schmeckt und
wie viel trüffel aroma ihr haben wollt
solltet ihr dann ein schwächeres oder
weniger nehmen und dann noch ein wenig
frisch geriebene muskatnuss so auch
davon nicht zu viel pfeffer und salz
start-stopp
55 alles was da drin ist schmeckt gut
die sagen dann ist immer da wird doch
immer was war eigentlich die
schlechteste bewertung
von libro für nudeln sechs und zehn
jahren sollte ich dann schlecht sagt
ehrlich für mich ist das schon perfekt
ein dann starten wir uns einzeln die
schnitzel robben die erstmal mit ein
bisschen wasser beiden seiten dann in
das doppel griffige mail an ruhig so ein
bisschen an drücken das wirklich überall
das mehl bindet und generell bei seiner
familie straße sollte man immer eine
trockene eine nasse hand machen das
schaffe ich aber in der realität
eigentlich wird nie suchst aber noch mal
dann ab ins sei dort auch von beiden
seiten dann gut abtropfen lassen zum
schluss enz planieren kannst immer was
von mir lernen jungs dann von beiden
seiten bedecken wo ich ordentlich an
drücken dass es wirklich brennt wo man
keine nackte stellen jetzt haben wir ein
wunderbar saniert ist schön dünn
im schnitt und das geben wir direkt rein
immer weg vom körper wir müssen das
ganze jetzt in bewegung halten damit das
schön so friert und so blasen wird aber
es war nicht so schlau aber jetzt kann
sich kein weiteres familien getrübt also
dadurch dass
sind packt sogar mit selbst mit an hier
unglaublich keinen tag persönlich halt
auch da mit vollem einsatz dabei zumeist
die schnitzel fertig und dann richtige
auch schon an
[Musik]
so mein lieber das crazy aus ganz cool
wie das sei also ein schnitzel trüffel
kartoffelpüree und fahrpreise werden wie
eine art geworden
es ist selbstverständlich ein echtes auf
jeden fall sehr krank
werden
der konzern geht nicht
probiere das ja ich probiere das noch
vielleicht ist ja 6 prozent waren ja
auch ein schnitzel ist geisteskrank ja
ich meine dank gerechnet dann war mir
schon sicher dass es lecker sein wird
jetzt nicht nur gespannt was noch zu
toppen
lässt sich ja nicht
[Musik]
das war's also keller ist leer was sagst
du also es wäre eigentlich zehn von zehn
gewesen aber weil ich halt heute beim
frühstücken neun von zehn gegeben ab und
beim mittagessen neuheit glaube ich da
mehr das unfertige schnitzel und vor
allem dem kartoffelpüree gegenüber wenn
das nur ein punkt oder ein halben punkt
besser deswegen muss ich hier schon
zwölf und damit die distanz zu dem
hacker gestern noch einmal klar wird
weil das war wirklich hausen mal klasse
richtig heiß
ich fühle mich sehr gut wäre es ganz
spannend auf jeden fall da brauche ich
dann der erste was es war
ein absoluter traum ich habe auch sehr
lecker und wir machen das hier weil
meine setzkasten ja sehr klar und dann
mache ich einen tatsächlich hier hab ich
gemacht die leute klatschen